here's how I know if my advertising is
working I take the total amount of
payroll that I spend on whatever Channel
I'm advertising on and then I divide
that by the total number of leads I got
from that advertising channel so for
example if it cost me a hundred thousand
dollars to have five people work in my
content department and I got a thousand
leads from my content they would mean it
cost me 100 per lead now to figure out
if my advertising is profitable I look
at my Revenue per lead and if my Revenue
per lead in this example is over 300 per
lead then I'm getting three to one or
more that's how I figure out whether my
advertising is working for platforms
that aren't just paid media